a chilly morning in New York City
and at the offices of the Senegalese
Association of America they are setting
up for a big crowd of fans to watch the
game the World Cup may be happening a
half world away in Qatar but for these
Senegalese fans there was only one place
to cheer their team on today we start
our first game to the World Cup against
uh Netherland and that's why we see the
people coming a lot here to support the
team to be behind the team to win the
game it's believed around 20 000
Senegalese live in the United States
that's a relatively small number
compared to people from other African
nations but the vast majority of
senegalese in America live here in the
Harlem neighborhood of New York city
where the Senegalese Association
provides help to anyone who needs it for
three decades now we offer immigration
services for folks who cannot afford
lawyers we also offer Social Services we
help people people who are sick people
unfortunately who pass away help them
bring the body home go to people to the
hospital as the game got underway
tensions Rose in the packed room
fans living every moment
from the bad decisions
to the near misses
[Applause]
to the last minute disappointments
a game of few chances ended with Senegal
losing two nil leaving the Lions of
taranga tamed and fans with much to
discuss especially with the next game
against the host Qatar and then Ecuador
if you go to the World Cup it means that
you have good players we're gonna take
that game seriously but I think we have
more resources to to beat the Qatar
hello
whatever the results for these Senegal
fans the World Cup party has already
started
Gabriel ozando Al Jazeera New York